good morning John it's Friday February
2nd this is the first day that I've done
a video on an even-numbered day I also
wanted to say hi to Lauren who made the
first brother 22.0 reply video on
YouTube well done
I'll change the battery pack that's not
OK okay I have to lose really quick
stuff now and I wanted to say hi to all
300 those people at the EPA conference
along the way to Sarasota Florida the
rest of this video will be watching what
I did this morning it's the opposite of
the rest of my movie magic videos where
it goes backward in time you're not
going forward in time at the beginning
and now you're going back so go back go
back
some of my friends were telling me last
night that my hair is sometimes a little
bit messy on Brotherhood 2.0 so last
night I went to bed with wet hair
I haven't actually touched it yet so I
want to see what it looks like in its
preserved State its kind of skateboard
ramp going on and like a wave and little
Tufts Tufts like I'm a baby bird I think
if I touched it it wouldn't actually
even do anything it's just gonna all
stay there
ooh okay much worse much worse than it
was no I look funny this is what my hair
looks like now that I've touched it I
don't have time to fix it though I'm
getting ready for my next jaunt I'm in
Orlando now and I'm about to be in
Sarasota Florida which is nearby Tampa
st. Petersburg that's an apology to all
or Landon's who are upset by my comments
that Orlando sucks actually no one
seemed upset at all I'm gonna list a
couple of reasons why Orlando doesn't
suck one reason is that my friend andrew
has the game Guitar Hero look how
awesome I look I'm playing david bowie's
ziggy stardust and I am playing David
Bowie Ziggy Stardust I'm just sliding up
and down the neck look at me look at me
having a good time
yeah it occurs to me that playing guitar
hero may be another one of those things
that feels cooler than it looks
another awesome thing about Orlando is
little Vietnam in Missoula Montana we
don't really have a lot of ethnic
diversity and it's really nice to have a
part of town here that's a little bit
different from everywhere else the
language is a little bit different and
it's written on a sticky bun the
religious icons are a little bit
different the fish are a little bit
different the smells are a little bit
different the eggs are a little bit
different than the lunch meat is strange
but generally when I go in one of these
stores I just end up buying candy and
now I'm gonna say my sign-off I'll see
you tomorrow no I'll see you on Monday